-The president staged
a deranged
and deeply reckless photo op
when he left the hospital,
despite still being symptomatic
with a highly infectious virus,
and used it as an occasion
to tell Americans
that COVID isn't a big deal.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The president left Walter Reed
Medical Center yesterday,
making sure to gratuitously
touch the handrail
a bunch of times
on his way down
and, as he walked by reporters,
they asked him
a pointed question
that really sums up the state
of his presidency quite well.
[ Camera shutter clicking ]
I know we do this a lot,
but imagine if, a year ago,
someone told you the president
would be asked,
"Do you think you may be
a super spreader?"
The only reaction is,
"What the [bleep] happened?"
It's like if I told you, a year
from now, someone would ask,
"Mr. President,
where did you put Montana?!"
I do feel like
the super spreader question's
not the one
you want to be getting
28 days before an election.
He's the president
and reporters are treating him
like he's the "Outbreak" monkey.
"Mr. President, how many people
do you intend to bite?
And a quick follow-up --
ankles or necks?"
Gonna give
his next press conference
by popping out of the bushes
and hissing at reporters
before ducking away
to dodge a tranq dart.
Did you get him, Curly?
"He's too fast!"
Usually, at the point in the
calendar, reporters are
asking the president questions
about the election.
In Trump's case, they're asking
him if he's Typhoid Larry.
"Mr. President,
if you win a second term,
is there anyone else you'd
like to personally infect?"
Of course, you got
to be careful with Trump
because he might think
super spreader is a compliment.
[ As Trump ]
My Secret Service code name is
Spread Eagle.
Y-Y-Yikes.
Yikes, to that.
Can we cover that up?
Someone Photoshop
a ThighMaster in there.
There you go.
That's better.
It's not good,
but it's a little better.
It's genuinely hard to recall
a moment in American life
that felt more unhinged
than the grotesque spectacle
we all witnessed last night --
an infectious president
on powerful steroids
and experimental drugs
walking around
with a potentially deadly virus,
making a big show
of leaving the hospital,
flying back
to the White House at sunset,
and, just before
Joe Biden's town hall,
taking his mask off
in front of the cameras
and visibly gasping for air,
like he's been guarding
LeBron James all night.
[ As Trump ]
[ Pants ]
I just, uh... [ Pants ]
gave 110%.
[ Pants ]
And I'm happy we held
LeBron to 38 point.
Looks like a "Solid Gold"
[ Laughing ] dancer
trying to hold the tableaux
until the camera's off.
[ Panting ]
[ Laughter ]
Looks like he just got back
from a class at No SoulCycle.
And, you know,
make sure to go to...
to vote for which one of those
three jokes you liked best.
It's still active.
You ever take a, you know,
way too big a bong rip
in college
and then,
you were too embarrassed,
so you tried to hold it in
for as long as you could
and then, you got so stoned,
you forgot
you were holding it in
and you somehow swallowed it?
That's what he looks like.
He either needs an oxygen mask
or some peanut butter
and a bag of Funyuns.
Seriously, was this stunt
supposed to convince us
that COVID isn't a big deal?
The only way this could've
been more of a cautionary tale
is if Trump started gnawing
on a microphone,
thinking it was a drumstick.
[ As Trump ]
See? I haven't lost
my sense of taste at all.
Man, they're not kidding
about extra crispy, though.
By the way, the only reason
we can even tell
that he was gasping for air
was that the highly
infectious president,
who is actively symptomatic
with a potential deadly virus,
took his mask off
once he got back
to the White House.
Wow. So the villain is unmasked
at the end of the episode.
The only thing missing
was Scooby and the gang.
-[ As Shaggy ]
Zoinks! It's Old Man Trump!
That was not good and I know it.
[ As Trump ]
I would've gotten away
with it, too,
if I just fired Velma
and replaced her
with Kellyanne Conway.
It's horrifying,
but I got to admit,
it's also, you know,
just good movie making.
It's always
a dramatic high point
when the villain
takes off his mask
so the innocent victim
can see their face.
The only thing missing
was the monologue
about how long he's been
waiting for this.
[ As Trump ]
Well, well...
[ Breathes deeply ]
...well.
[ Laughter ]
I just love how he took it off
like it was a big reveal.
We're familiar
with your face, my bro.
The only way that
would've been worth it
is if you were premiering
your new Selleck 'stache.
And then, after that
insane spectacle,
Trump shot a taxpayer-funded
campaign-style ad
with dramatic music,
as well as one of his weird
straight-to-camera
Twitter videos where he rambled
about how his experience proves
COVID is not that big a deal.
-I learned so much
about coronavirus
and one thing that's
for certain --
don't let it dominate you.
Don't be afraid of it.
You're gonna beat it.
Don't let it dominate.
Don't let it take
over your lives.
Don't let that happen.
We have the greatest
country in the world.
We're going back.
We're going back to work.
We're gonna be out front.
And I know there's a risk,
there's a danger,
but that's okay.
And, now, I'm better
and maybe I'm immune.
I don't know.
[ As Trump ]
Maybe I'm an X-Man now.
Maybe I can fly.
Maybe I have super speed!
Like the Flash.
I don't know.
I tried to ask my doctors,
but I couldn't hear them
over Judge Jeanine.
We love the judge,
don't we, folks?
The voice of an angel
that's been lit on fire.
And what do you mean,
you don't know?
I thought you said you learned
so much about coronavirus.
That seems like something
you'd want to look into first,
especially since scientists
have been studying it for,
I don't know, months now.
He sounds like a fifth grader
bull[bleep] his way
through an oral report.
"I learned so much
about the Louisiana Purchase,
yet, there are many answers
we will never know.
Was it the purchase of Louisiana
or was it a purchase made
by someone named Louisiana?"
Also, why does this video
look like a commercial
for a reverse mortgage?
If there was ever a commercial
that needed the pharmaceutical
disclaimer, it's this one.
[ Speaking rapidly ]
Honestly, it's getting
hard to imagine
new ways for him
to spread the virus.
He's been holding rallies
and indoor events without masks
or social distancing;
walking around near other people
while he's infectious;
taking a sad,
slow ride in his motorcade,
like a Pope
who just got [bleep]canned
for stealing office supplies
from the Vatican.
[ English accent ]
And there he goes,
Pope Donaldus,
sadly waving a goodbye.
A fitting end for a pontiff
who hid multiple
printer cartridges
in his miter.
And, now, he's back
to the White House
and ditching his mask
while he's still contagious.
He's exhaling a toxic virus,
like one of the Joker's
poison flowers...
Nerd life!
...and, instead
of keeping his distance,
he immediately gets rid
of the one thing
that could provide some level
of protection
for the people around him,
which isn't just
unsafe for them.
It also sends an incredibly
dangerous signal
to his supporters that,
even if they might be
infectious,
they don't need to wear a mask,
a message he's been
sending for weeks
by claiming, without evidence,
that masks can have
negative effects
and mocking Joe Biden
for wearing one.
-There are a lot of people
who think
that masks are not good.
I don't wear a mask like him.
Every time you see him,
he's got a mask.
He could be speaking
200 feet away from it
and he shows up with the
biggest mask I've ever seen.
Did you ever see a man
that likes a mask
as much as him?
Because you know what?
It gives him
a feeling of security.
If I were a psychiatrist --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right?
No, I'd say --
[ Cheering ]
I'd say this guy's got
some big issues.
-If you were a psychiatrist,
your patients
would have to treat you.
"I'm hearing voices, doc."
[ As Trump ]
Me too. What would
you recommend?
"I don't know.
Have you tried lithium?"
I wonder how that mixes
with dexamethasone.
That's my COVID medication.
Did I mention I have COVID?
You probably didn't hear me
through my mask.
Oh, wait.
I'm not wearing one.
Also, what do you mean,
he's got the biggest mask
you've ever seen?
Could it just be that
your masks are the same size,
but covers less of your face
because your head is the size
of a waterlogged picnic ham?
And what that is
is like it would happen
when there's a picnic
and it starts to rain, so,
you know, everybody grabs
something, they run for cover,
but then, once you're
underneath an awning
or whatever, someone says,
"Did anyone grab the ham?!"
So it's a real thing.
And even after Trump
was hospitalized with COVID
and given a battery of powerful
and experimental drugs,
his supporters are still
mocking Biden for wearing masks,
like Rudy Giuliani,
who said this
after a Fox anchor asked him
about Biden urging the president
to listen to scientists
and support masks --
-What would you say
to Joe Biden there?
-Well, I would say to Joe
that you don't really understand
what scientists are.
First of all, listen to your
doctors, that's for sure.
They know your personal history.
Doctors really
aren't scientists.
-Do you think you know more
about scientists
because you were created
by them?
Rudy's just a bunch
of different body parts
of deceased mobsters,
sewn together
and shocked with electricity
until they came to life.
[ European accent ]
Well, I couldn't find a neck,
but maybe it'll work, anyway.
Rise, my creation!
Second, maybe your doctors
aren't really scientists,
but then again,
I just assume your doctors work
under the 59th Street Bridge.
Doc, I got a rash.
"Uh, you could try these pills.
They fell off the back
of a truck."
And then, there was Trump
campaign adviser Jason Miller,
who criticized Biden
for making mask wearing
such a big part of his campaign.
-I'd say that,
with regard to Joe Biden,
I think, too often,
he's used the mask as a prop.
A mask is very important,
but even if he's --
He could be 20, 30 feet away
from the nearest person
and still have the mask on.
That's not gonna change
anything that's out there.
But also, we've seen,
with Joe Biden,
I mean, we can't all just stay
in our basement
for the rest of our lives.
We have to get out there
and live our lives
and take this on,
develop the vaccine,
develop more therapeutics,
and defeat it.
-Alright, a couple of things.
First,
what's up with your head, man?
You look like someone
pumped too much air
into a football.
Second, yes, he's trying
to model good behavior
and lead by example,
by promoting mask wearing.
Also, you work for Trump.
You're the last person
who should accuse anyone
of using a prop.
Trump was literally caught
signing a blank piece of paper
over the weekend,
like a teenager practicing
his mom's signature
to get him out of gym class.
[ As Trump ]
I'm as mad as you are, Coach,
but you read the note.
"And I'm sorry, Don.
Your mother's name is Mom?"
[ As Trump ]
Oh, no, I biffed it!
And I love that that's
what they're still going with,
the stupid basement line
for Biden,
despite the fact that,
in this clip from August,
he's biking more
than Donald Trump has biked,
I don't know, ever?
I mean, that is possible, right?
It's very hard to picture
Trump on a bike.
Just the swinging
of the leg over the frame.
Or the desiring of it.
Just so hard
to picture Trump saying...
[ As Trump ]
Should we take the bikes out?
Nice day for a bike ride.
Mel!
[ Laughter ]
Should we take
the bikes out, Mel?!
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna go -- Mel!
I'm gonna go check the tires,
make sure --
Oh -- oh -- okay!
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Check your mail.
[ Laughter ]
Let me love you, Mel!
Yeah, whatever, sure.
Biden's a basement troll.
Go for it.
And what do you mean,
we have to get out there
and live our lives
and take this on?
That makes no sense.
These people are so dumb.
They genuinely do not seem
to understand
the basics
of viral transmission.
For example,
conservative commentator
Hugh Hewitt tweeted...
Well, I mean, that depends.
If Reagan was shot
because he was juggling a bunch
of loaded guns
in the Oval Office
and one of them
accidentally went off,
I feel like the applause
might've been a bit more muted.
It's like...
[ Clapping] "This guy."
The president got the best
taxpayer-funded
medical care in the world
and, instead of ensuring
that every American
gets similar treatment,
he's telling them to go out
and fight the virus
because it's just not
that big a deal.
He's proven, once again,
he has no regard
for any life other than his own.
He's recklessly putting
others in harm's way
by holding
super spreading events,
walking around without a mask
while he's infectious,
and telling people
who don't have access
to the same healthcare he has
not to be afraid
of a deadly virus
that's killed more than
200,000 Americans.
And he's doing it all
to pump up his own ego.
I'm no psychiatrist,
but I think it's safe to say...
[ Cheering and applause ]
-This guy's got some big issues.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses
and they need your help.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.